direkt vor unserer tür nur vier
lichtjahre entfernt könnte es leben
geben jetzt wurde sogar ein dritter
exoplaneten orbit um unseren nächsten
nachbarn stern proxima centauri entdeckt
der neue exoplaneten ist der leichteste
und innerste unseres nachbar sterns was
wissen wir noch über den neuzugang und
hält sich hier möglicherweise
ausschuss leben versteckt klicks um sein
zum future die gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocken nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
jetzt wissen wir es sind mindestens drei
exoplaneten die den nächsten stern
proxima centauri umkreisen neben seinen
bislang bekannten begleiter proxima b
und proxy mattsee wurde jetzt ein
dritter planet bei proxima centauri
aufgespürt für die astronomie ist das
eine super spannende erkenntnis denn
proxima centauri ist unser direkter
nachbar zahlreiche wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler feiern diese
spektakuläre entdeckung diese entdeckung
zeigt dass unsere nachbarstadt eine
reihe interessanter neuer welten besitzt
die in reichweite für künftige studien
und sogar exploration liegen so sagt es
der astrophysiker maria der den dritten
planeten gefunden hat was wissen wir
bereits über diese neue welt könnte sich
dort außerirdisches leben versteckt
halten und können wir in zukunft
möglicherweise wirklich zu diesen
fremden welten reisen die antworten auf
all diese fragen und noch viel mehr gibt
es jetzt hier von mir nicht nur in der
science fiction sondern auch in der
astrophysik und raumfahrt hat man
proxima centauri ganz genau wie sie es
handelt sich um einen roten zwerg stern
unser nächster nachbar im all für
künftige raummissionen eine extrem
spannende welt denn das system liegt nur
etwa vier lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt als roter zwerg gehört proxima
centauri zu der klasse von stern in der
milchstraße die wohl mit abstand am
häufigsten sind gemeint sind damit die
kleinsten und noch aktiven sterne sie
weiß nur etwa 1 bis 7 zehntel der
sonnenmasse auf wie läuft die kernfusion
im inneren der roten zwerge eher auf
sparflamme umkreis wird proxima centauri
von den beiden planeten centauri b und c
die bereits vor sechs jahren 2016
beziehungsweise vor zwei jahren 2020
aufgespürt werden konnten proxima
centauri b ist etwa so groß wie die erde
und umrundet den zwerg sterben in einem
abstand der es zumindest in der theorie
erlauben würde dass flüssiges wasser auf
ihm existiert dieser eher zwilling
befindet sich in der sogenannten
habitablen zone dass sich ihr leben
verwirkt ist deswegen vorstellbar
dagegen sprechen allerdings nach ansicht
einiger forscherinnen und forscher die
extrem heftigen strahlungsausbruch diese
könnten eine atmosphäre um proxima
centauri zerstören fachleute weltweit
diskutieren immer wieder wie
lebensfreundlich dieser eher zwilling
wirklich ist eine studie über die wir
zuletzt berichtet hatten geht davon aus
dass die strahlungs ausbrüche
verlängerungen der sternen achse sind
und an den polen austreten und damit die
planeten gar nicht treffen können da sie
nie die planeten eben erreichen
zahlreiche medien suchen besucher sind
deshalb überzeugt davon dass sich dort
außerirdisches leben verbergen könnte
und tatsächlich mysteriöse signale die
möglicherweise von dort stammen hatten
auch seriöse wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler seit ihrer entdeckung
vor zwei jahren 2020 beschäftigt wir
hatten darüber 26 lucia berichtet ein
astronomie team hatte damals ein
radiosignal auf der erde empfangen das
möglicherweise von dem proxima centauri
system stammen könnte das signal wurde
auf die bezeichnung break listen
candidate one blc one getauft vor allem
die frequenz versetzte astronomen und
astronom weltweit ins staunen sie lag
exakt bei
982 002 megahertz und erscheint somit im
wellen diagramm schaut wie eine nadel
und genau diese schmalbandige lässt die
fachwelt aufhorchen denn das gilt als
mögliches charakteristikum eines
künstlich erzeugten signals was die
fachwelt zudem verwunderte die typische
drift frequenz in signal verlauf die
charakteristisch ist für quellen die
sich bewegen das entspricht also im
gesamtbild den kennzeichen einer techno
signatur hiermit sind im großen ganzen
messbare wirkungen oder eigenschaften
gemeint die beweise für vergangene oder
gegenwärtige technologien liefern
könnten die hoffnung war groß endlich
ausleben aufgespürt zu haben doch eine
umfangreiche analyse des vergangenen
jahres 2021 brachte dann die große
enttäuschung demnach können die
rätselhaften signale nicht aus den
unendlichen weiten des kosmos stammen
stattdessen müssen sie ihr russischen
ursprungs sein und tatsächlich ensi
denjenigen signalen die auch von
elektrischen geräten ausgesandt werden
die erkenntnisse deuten darauf hin dass
es sich bei den signalen und
störgeräusche von menschlicher technik
handelt auch wenn wir die genauen
quellen nicht lokalisieren kommen also
auch das ist umstritten wie steht jetzt
erst mal studie gegen studie
wahrscheinlich werden wir keine toaster
die die erde umkreisen finden deshalb
ausgeschlossen ist es eben nicht dass
sich potenzielle es außerirdisches leben
im umfeld der sogenannten roten zwergen
findet eine aktuelle entdeckung
erweitert jetzt unser wissen und proxima
centauri denn es gibt noch einen dritten
planeten unseren nachbarn stern
aufgespürt werden konnte dieser durch
ein verdächtiges signal bereits vor zwei
jahren 2020 hatten spektral messungen
mit dem espresso spektrographen am very
large telescope der europäischen
südsternwarte eso in chile diese
entdeckung gemacht mit der hilfe der
sogenannten radialgeschwindigkeit
methode konnte der planet dann letztlich
dingfest gemacht werden dabei fanden
astronomen astronomen im spektrum eines
sterns nach feinsten periodischen
schwankungen in der bewegung relativ zu
uns doch das stellte sich alles gar
nicht als so einfach heraus denn die
starken strahlungs ausbrüche des
werkstoffs könnten auch seine
rotationsgeschwindigkeit beeinflussen
waren das also echte planeten signale
oder nur steuereffekte um ganz
sicherzugehen hatten die fachleute dann
proxima centauri noch genauer mit dem
espresso spektrografen ins visier
genommen so stand dann schnell fest es
ist ein planet der das wiederkehrende
signal im spektrum verursacht unser
nachbar stern hat also mindestens drei
begleiter der neu entdeckte planet
proxima centauri die braucht gut fünf
tage umsatz stern zum laufen dabei hält
er sich zwischen dem stern und seiner
habitablen zone auf also den bereich um
einen stern in dem es flüssiges wasser
auf der planetenoberfläche existieren
könnte es handelt sich somit um den
innersten der drei planeten und proxima
centauri seine mittlere
oberflächentemperatur könnte nach
ansicht der fachleute und 86 grad
celsius betragen nur vier millionen
kilometer ist seine bahn vom stern
entfernt zum besseren vergleich der
abstand zwischen erde und sonne beträgt
dagegen etwa 150 millionen kilometer der
neue planet proxima centauri de ist mit
rund einem viertel der erdmasse außerdem
leichter und deutlich kleiner als die
beiden anderen begleiter überhaupt ist
seine entdeckung eine gelungene premiere
denn es handelt sich um den leichtesten
bekannten exoplaneten der je mit der
hilfe der radialgeschwindigkeit technik
entdeckt werden konnte seine schwerkraft
ist so gering dass sie sein stern nur
mit etwa 40 zentimetern pro sekunde hin
und her bewegt die ist in der aktuellen
studie heißt dennoch ist es also
gelungen den geringen schwankungen des
sterns auf die schliche zu kommen die
astronomen astronom feiern ihre
entdeckung deswegen extrem einer der
entdecker der eso wissenschaftler pedro
fieber sagt das zeigt dass die
radialgeschwindigkeit technik das
potenzial hat leichte planeten wie
unseren eigenen zu entdecken die
vermutlich die häufigsten in unserer
galaxie und die möglicherweise leben wie
wir es kennen berger der neue fund des
dritten exoplaneten rund um unseren
nachbarn ist für die forschung also ein
wichtiger schritt jetzt sind drei
exoplaneten bekannt die nur etwas mehr
als vier lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt sind die fachleute sind sich
sicher dass weitere spannende entdeckung
und um proxima centauri und seine
exoplaneten folgen werden trotz des
guten zwecks im zentrum ein zwilling
unseres sonnensystems so gibt es sogar
schon überlegungen unserem nachbar
system einen besuch abzustatten ein
projekt der breakthrough initiativ start
die natur sondern mit licht segeln
antreiben und so innerhalb von 20 jahren
proxima centauri erreichen der physiker
wie löw jedenfalls sieht vor allem den
planeten proxima b als möglicher heimat
einer möglichen außerirdischen
zivilisation außerirdisches leben auf
vielmehr planet möglich da geht es also
in diesem video um die roten zwerge und
mögliches leben auf dem planeten die sie
umkreisen super spannende erkenntnis
also anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt